et on va plus loin avec un madame
Mustapha vidi actrice adjoint de la
rédaction de L'Express hebdomadaire qui
fait sa Une sur la guerre secrète Russie
il y a nos espions sont-ils à la hauteur
face à vous il sera forcément à la
hauteur ségotierry beansky chroniqueur
international ici à France 24 bonjour
Gautier
depuis 5 semaines maintenant et le
théâtre de contestation consécutive vous
le savez à la mort de Marsa mini cette
jeune femme qui a été interpellé pour un
voile mal porté qui n'en est pas
ressorti vivante sur une répression
menée donc depuis par l'Iran sur son
territoire et même au-delà l'armée
iranienne a bombardé la nuit dernière
des zones du Kurdistan irakien c'était
pas la première fois viser des opposants
du pouvoir de Téhéran au sein du Parti
démocratique du Kurdistan écoutez le
porte-parole du ministère iranien des
Affaires étrangères suivi de la réponse
justement de ce parti démocratique du
Kurdistan
la République islamique d'Iran croit au
respect de la souveraineté et de
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Irak et
cette question est très importante pour
nous
dans le même temps les groupes
séparatistes et terroristes qui se
trouvent à l'intérieur du territoire
irakien en particulier dans la région du
Kurdistan direct viole non seulement la
sécurité de la République islamique
d'Iran et la sécurité des citoyens ainsi
que des gardes frontières de la
République islamique d'Iran par ses
actions terroristes armées mais aussi il
viole la souveraineté de l'Irak
par conséquent la République islamique
d'Iran salut et soutient l'expansion du
contrôle de l'Irak le long de la zone
frontalière commune entre l'Iran et
l'Irak en particulier dans la région du
Kurdistan en direct
nous espérons que le gouvernement
irakien avec cette action d'expansion de
souveraineté et de domination empêchera
les actions en continu de groupe
séparatistes armés contre la République
islamique d'Iran dans les zones
frontalières
nous n'avons jamais eu besoin d'apporter
des armes dans le pays parce que l'Iran
lui-même regorge d'armes de plus il n'y
a pas une seule preuve que nous ou même
nos alliés ayons transféré des armistes
enfin nous n'avons jamais constitué une
menace pour la région du Kurdistan et
pour le territoire irakien
de voir dans ce mouvement
un mouvement résolument hostile le Parti
démocratique du Kurdistan au point
d'aller bombarder ses positions qui en
distenant irakien
alors qu'il soit hostile à la République
islamique oui c'est pas c'est pas
complètement
inédit c'est même le principe de ce
parti qui par définition demande la
démocratie et demande des choses qui ne
sont pas actuellement en plaçant en Iran
c'est une inimitié qui date depuis
longtemps ce n'est pas la première fois
évidemment que l'Iran va pourchasser sur
des territoires étrangers les membres du
Parti
démocratique du kurdistanbiran il y a
même eu des assassinats sur le sol
européen contre ces dirigeants de ce
parti donc ça cette partie là n'est pas
étonnante après ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que ces derniers jours en Iran
l'attention elle s'est concentrée sur le
clandestan iranien cette fois-ci les
populations Kurdes d'Iran qui sont entre
guillemets les plus rebelles
actuellement même si la contestation
continue dans d'autres endroits c'est
juste la masse de personnes qui est plus
importante et la répression en face et
aussi très importante
à ma famille c'est une kurde iranienne à
la base et même si dans cette dans cette
histoire il faut vraiment saluer qu'il y
a eu une unité très forte au sein des
Iraniens et ça a été jusqu'ici même une
technique un peu de du gouvernement de
dire voilà c'est que les Kurdes ou c'est
que les balouches etc tandis qu'en fait
c'est vraiment tous les peuples entre
guillemets d'Iran sont unis mais là
comme la concentration est très forte et
la tension est très forte dans le
prédestin iranien c'est une manière en
fait de riposter non seulement par la
répression à l'intérieur enfin en gros
les cibles à l'extérieur Téhéran on
vient de l'entendre à nouveau fait
pression clairement un Gautier sur
Bagdad pour isoler cette région et plus
précisément pour à l'intérieur même du
Kurdistan irakien en chassé donc c'est
ces groupes considérés comme hostile par
Téhéran qui a réagi et condamne
fermement ces frappes
et oui parce que l'Irak ne peut pas
faire autrement que de condamner ses
frappes et en même temps elle est
extrêmement gênée par les requêtes
iranienne pourquoi parce que ce
Kurdistan irakien depuis en fait c'est
issu de la première guerre du Golfe
puisque les Américains avaient imposé
une zone de
surveillance ou de non-vols une zone
aérienne sur le Kurdistan irakien et
également sur la partie shit du pays
Basora et de ce fait là c'est développé
dans ce Kurdistan irakien un pays qui
est quasiment
autonome en tout cas qui a un parlement
qui a une culture propre qui a même
frappé monnaie à une époque et qui de ce
fait là a beaucoup à perdre d'une d'un
manière dont la contagion pourrait se
faire et qui a produit même et à nourri
ses propres relations internationales
par exemple le Kurdistan irakien n'est
pas spécialement opposé à Israël etc et
donc ce pays qui est en gestation en
quelque sorte et bien sûr une épine dont
le pied des Iraniens parce que c'est
vrai que ça peut servir de refuge pour
des Iraniens mais c'est aussi dans le
pied de Bagdad mais Bagdad n'a pas
forcément et plutôt moins que plus n'a
pas de d'influence encore moins
militaire sur ce Kurdistan irakien et
donc condamner les frappes c'est dire en
quelque sorte on se met pas à dos les
Kurdes d'Irak mais en même temps ce que
demandent Téhéran si j'ai bien compris
c'est-à-dire que les troupes Kurd
iraniennes se tiennent à 120 km de la
frontière et ça bah ça ça peut ne passer
que par le gouvernement de Bagdad donc
Bagdad est pris entre deux feux dans
cette histoire
c'est une région en fait les Kurdes
c'est un c'est une nation entre
guillemets divisée en quatre étapes
l'Irak l'Iran la Turquie la Syrie et
dans chaque évidemment il y a une sorte
de solidarité kurde mais après ça veut
pas dire que le les Kurdes qui dirigent
à Erbil qui est la capitale du Kurdistan
autonome d'Irak soutiennent de manière
militaire ou voilà c'est juste qu'il y a
comme et il y a quand même une ingérence
à un moment donné de l'Iran contre son
voisin qui est dira qu'avec qu'ils ont
quand même été en guerre pendant 8 ans
donc c'est quand même significatif que
l'Iran traverse la frontière pour voilà
c'est comme si nous on allait traverser
la frontière allemande parce que il y
avait des terroristes là-bas sans
l'accord de l'Allemagne donc c'est c'est
pas non plus anodin à côté oui
excusez-moi un petit détail je pense que
nous avons une carte
qui montre les populations kurde un
cheval sur quatre pays et bah non nous
n'avons pas cher
ça intervient alors que côté turc parce
qu'on va continuer à parler évidemment
de ces populations Kurdes d'un côté turc
au gombo bombarde les forces Kurdes
cette fois de Syrie au point d'envisager
même une opération terrestre en
représailles à l'attentat à d'Istanbul
de la semaine dernière écouter le
ministre turc de l'Intérieur
après les opérations que nous avons
menées au cours desquelles
l'organisation terroriste a subi de
lourdes pertes le nécessaire sera fait
pour apporter une nouvelle réponse à
cette attaque de la façon la plus ferme
qui soit
on le voit donc les Turcs sont prêts à
agir il y a toujours une coordination à
Madame entre Téhéran et Ankara
aujourd'hui je pense pas qu'il y ait une
coordination mais il y a des intérêts
qui sont communs la Turquie de toute
façon est dans une bataille historique
avec les ses propres Kurdes à elle et
c'est sûr que là il y a convergence
d'intérêts entre Téhéran et Istanbul
puisque ils ne veulent pas que les
Kurdes puissent entre guillemets ils ont
toujours eu très peur en fait de cette
contagion autonome ils se sont dit si
l'Irak si ça se passe en Irak pourquoi
ça se passerait pas en Turquie où il y a
13 millions de Kurdes pourquoi ça se
paraisserait pas en Iran où il y a aussi
des millions de Kurdes donc voilà
ils ont peur que l'expérience irakienne
puisse s'aimer ailleurs il y a eu un
référendum d'indépendance au Kurdistan
d'Irak d'ailleurs en 2017 qui il y avait
eu même s'il n'a pas été créé ce
Kurdistan syrien le rojava voilà il y a
eu la volonté on se rappelle tous aussi
quand même on a un peu tendance à
oublier de la résistance incroyable des
Kurdes face à daesh à l'état islamique
aujourd'hui on peut quand même dire que
toute une partie de
l'Irak de la Syrie n'ont pas ont été
libérés de l'État islamique grâce à
l'action des péchés comme on les appelle
donc
cette zone de peuplement Kurdes on le
voit qui effectivement vous le disiez
dame est à cheval sur ces quatre états
turquis Syrie Irak Iran
voilà ils sont toujours soupçonnés
évidemment les cures de s'entraider mais
c'est pas forcément c'est aussi une
entraide qui a été très utile par
exemple pendant la lune contre l'État
islamique Gauthier il y a une alliance
objective aujourd'hui de Téhéran ou en
cas où il mène ces deux pays enfin
l'Iran et la Turquie des combats
totalement distinct avec des intérêts
distincts contre des adversaires
distinct parce que le pouvoir en tout
cas au Kurdistan irakien n'est pas
hostile à la Turquie donc tout à fait
c'est cette autonomie dont parle madame
qui est assez étonnante je parlais aussi
d'Israël c'est-à-dire que ce Kurdistan
irakien a pris sa distance avec une
forme de déterminisme politique qui
aurait voulu par exemple qu'il soit
radicalement hostile à la Turquie et de
fait de ce point de vue là l'émanation
du pkka comme nous voilà comme en
revanche la Turquie en accuse les
kuriens tout à fait ça n'est pas du tout
cette émanation et d'une certaine
manière d'ailleurs les les cures de
Dirac s'autorise à avoir cette politique
étrangère propre et qui n'est pas
justement lié à au mouvement dont on
pense qu'il est presque universel dans
le monde kurde c'est-à-dire le PKK
abdoulah jahlan je signale simplement
qu'il y a une époque justement pour
reparler de la Turquie
erdoğan avait choisi le dialogue avec
qui est toujours emprisonné de 90 sur
son île dans la merde marin et que
c'était près à aboutir sur sur un accord
ça veut dire aussi il faut pardon c'est
un truc d'opportunisme mais par
opportunité mais ça veut dire aussi
qu'aujourd'hui plus F2 on se sent menacé
non seulement par l'économie mais aussi
par la sécurité on en a vu le cas avec
l'attentat d'Istanbul plus il est
finalement enclin à
rejeter ça enfin à détourné les regards
sur le sur les Kurdes d'Istanbul sert de
prétex on a bien vite trouvé finalement
un coupable pour se donner une raison
d'envahir ensuite le nord de la Syrie
pour les Turcs disons que oui c'était
assez rapide le moment je pense que les
Turcs ça fait un moment qu'ils avaient
qu'ils avaient ça en tête
ces événements en tout cas les
interviennent alors qu'à la Coupe du
monde en au Qatar les Iraniens qui
disputaient leur premier match de la
compétition face aux Anglais ont
ostensiblement un bout des rimes
nationales lèvres close manière de
montrer leur désaccord avec le pouvoir
iranien ont été une réaction elle n'a
pas tardé aujourd'hui on le voit sur ces
sur ces images il y a pas eu de
chantonné par cette sélection iranienne
vous voyez ces joueurs qui s'épaule mais
qui se donnent la colade mais pas de
réaction les lèvres
ostensiblement closes lors de cette hym
oui c'était un symbole important c'est
vrai que ce qui différencie ce mouvement
de contestation de d'autres mouvements
qui ont pu avoir lieu avant en Iran
c'est qu'il y a entre guillemets des
célébrités iraniennes des actrices des
footballeurs des personnes de premier
plan qui ont montré une forme de
solidarité avec avec les événements
actuels ça peut être des formes de
solidarité très dangereuses comme
certaines actrices qui se sont montrés
dévoilées certaines qui ont été arrêtées
bon là les joueurs ont d'entre-deux
c'est à dire que ils n'ont pas forcément
dénoncé de manière très flagrante mais
ils ont
il y a quand même un message après des
opposants dans la communauté
d'opposition on va dire iranienne qu'on
considère un peu que c'est qu'il fallait
encore plus loin mais ne pas jouer et ne
pas jouer et avoir des actes plus plus
importants vu l'intensité de la
répression actuelle Gauthier c'est
courageux de leur part ils risquent quoi
en rentrant en Iran si effectivement il
boude systématiquement leur hymne
national alors disons qu'on ne sait pas
d'ailleurs si l'on rentrait en Iran
parce que c'est vrai que malgré tout
l'acte et courageux d'autant qu'on les a
beaucoup critiqués y compris en Iran
puisqu'ils sont allés voir le président
raciste afin d'avoir une espèce de
onction pour pour leur campagne dans le
Mondial c'est à la fois bien sûr elle
n'est pas de même nature et de même
niveau mais il y a évidemment le danger
du régime iranien mais il y a cette
cette espèce d'état hors norme et hors
contrôlable qui est la FIFA la FIFA est
capable on le voit la FIFA est capable
de dire à des équipes vous ne porterez
pas le brassard LGBT vous ferez ceci
sinon ça sera une amende mais c'est
énorme rappelez-vous aussi que la
dernière compétition la mairie du Munich
avait été interdite de d'illuminer le
stade Arena avec les couleurs LGBT par
la FIFA donc ça veut dire que si vous
voulez les joueurs iraniens risquent la
double peine en quelque sorte c'est à
dire à la fois de la part du régime et
c'est évidemment le plus grave mais par
cette espèce de relativisme ou de
neutralité de façade de la part de la
FIFA qui elle n'est jamais en reste
lorsqu'ils lorsque justement il s'agit
d'attribuer la Coupe du Monde au Qatar
et de quelle manière mais lorsque vous
avez des protestations élémentaires qui
sont basiques dans la défense de de
l'être humain alors là ça ne va pas pour
elle donc effectivement je m'excuse de
faire cette digression la plus le fait
le plus important et bien sûr le fait
qu'il à chanter là c'est quelque chose
enfin je sais pas je suis gay disait
Janine Fantino samedi et puis dimanche
il interdit ou lundi il interdit de port
du brassard au Britannique
son objectif est de faire en sorte que
finalement les événements politiques
soient vraiment à la marge de de la
Coupe du monde que non mais pas trop en
avant justement les dissensions je sais
pas comment ça va se passer sur Iran
États-Unis mais bon pareil il pourrait y
avoir aussi pas mal de de tension de
mettre tout ça de côté de mettre de côté
les droits de l'homme et de dire ce
n'est que un événement footballistique
et c'est l'heure de réduire
politique bon elle peut être un peu et
en même temps je la prétention des
cathariens dans leur cérémonie
d'ouverture hier c'était précisément
alors peut-être pour reprendre à rebours
ces critiques de délivrer un message
politique
on le sait on le sait avec le PSG en
France aujourd'hui on publie une sur le
site de l'Express une enquête sur
comment le carré VIP du Parc des Princes
et devenu une sorte d'ambassade du Qatar
en France parce que le
Qatar utilise de toute façon la
diplomatie du football depuis toujours
donc c'est vrai que c'est assez étonnant
de vouloir dépolitiser l'événement alors
que le pays haute et lui-même un des
principaux pays à utiliser ce soft power
et du coup la politique reprend ses
droits avec ce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui
des des joueurs Iraniens qui tout
proportion gardée bien sûr prennent
néanmoins un risque fort parce que ils
ont accompli eux dans leur carrière
quelque chose de sans doute extrêmement
phénoménal et on vient hein en Iran le
fait d'être de voilà d'être des stars de
leur de leurs compétition de leur sport
et de pouvoir tout perdre finalement sur
un geste de ce type on voit des Anglais
aussi mettre genou à plataire parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas porter ce brassard
leur fédération les y interdit et
surtout il y a le risque d'être
sanctionné sportivement c'est à dire les
cartons jaunes donc voilà de se voir
sanctionner dans la compétition la
politique reprend ses droits mais tant
mieux oui mais parce que justement les
joueurs iraniens ils sont soumis à une
pression qui est celle de la répression
et qu'ils sont concernés par ça même si
ce sont des célébrités donc c'est encore
plus courageuse ça veut dire que quand
on est vraiment
dont face à l'adversité et bien on
réagit en tant que citoyen et tant mieux
et tant mieux et en plus avec des
risques que les risques que vous avez
soulignés moi je suis stupéfait de voir
cette cette espèce de cécité de la part
des instances du football vis-à-vis de
ce qui tient justement à l'élémentaire
quand vous avez par exemple un certain
nombre de joueurs qui veulent dire leur
opinion on leur dit ah non c'est de la
politique mais par ailleurs on leur fait
des injonctions contradictoires c'est à
dire qu'on dit il faut que vous soyez
vous participiez à des offres
caritatives mais quand il s'agit des
choses alimentaires c'est-à-dire les
droits par exemple des personnes ne vont
sexuelles ou les droits de tout des
femmes et des hommes en Iran alors là il
y a plus personne et deux une certaine
manière quand on parle de l'esprit
neutre et de l'esprit sportif qui est
censé éclairer l'humanité bah là c'est
l'inverse le plan de plonge dans le dans
le noir
que le football c'est pas assez pas en
tout cas je trouve aujourd'hui un monde
très progressiste il y a pas toujours
pas de de footballeurs de premier plan
qui est vraiment dissons homosexualité
ou voilà et c'est quand même un truc
quelque chose qui aujourd'hui en 2022
est très étonnant je trouve cette ce
manque de progressisme dans le monde du
football c'est une belle conclusion
merci beaucoup madame Mustapha merci
Gautier c'était on va plus loin
rendez-vous dans 3 minutes pour un
nouveau journal rester avec nous dans
Paris
[Musique]